good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday it's a
beautiful day here in NYC for day two of
phase two hey Claude hyd hey Jax we are
both - look at our hair backs because
mine's dirty I don't know if yours is
but like literally I had the craziest
dream last night that I woke up
literally like I had just went to
SoulCycle like dripping sweat like down
my neck it was a craziest dream like we
were we were like on the run and we
needed a place to stay ended up staying
at Geoffrey Epstein's house and then we
like owed him a favor and like we were
just like running from Jeffrey Epstein
like for months seems like me you Ben
and Zach and I was freaking out I
literally for the first time in my life
out of my sleep shot up and I was like
oh and I woke that up it was so scary
and that's why my hair is dirty and
slicked back with a bun and some clips
because my hair is like literally
sopping wet Wow I wash my hair on Sunday
night so it should be clean but like I
woke up today and it just hurt like it
feels like I'm on day 6 so it looks like
I'm on day 6 a slicked back button I
just I couldn't be bothered today to
deal with my hair I'm just I just can't
Shanta and wind yeah um I would let you
share an experience that I think you and
many people will find interesting
ok so yesterday was phase one faith day
1 of phase 2 in New York which means
alfresco dining is open and yesterday
also happens to be my father-in-law's
birthday so we're like great we will go
out to dinner outside and I won't say
the restaurant because honestly it's not
the restaurants fault but like we sat at
dinner and I there were cockroaches
crawling literally I couldn't stand I
mean I couldn't sit I had to keep
getting up and it was just on the
building on the floor because you can't
eat inside so a lot of four restaurants
have gotten creative and made more
tables outside like some of them even
took parts of the street so that all the
tables are six feet apart and I don't
want to bash the restaurant because they
did a good job it's lit it's not their
[ __ ] fault like it's just New York
but it was one of the most disgusting
experiences like of my entire life and I
don't even want to alfresco dining more
like I've got to move oh my god I am
shook like I was I didn't
alfresco dining esterday I was like I'm
gonna save it you know I don't need it
right now like I'm gonna go when I need
to go maybe like make reservation go
with my friends like make it a big to-do
I am disgusted that is disgusting I
that's actually the only thing on earth
that could spoil my appetite is a roach
in the vicinity and so I guess it just
won't be going to restaurants anymore
that's ni yo there are certain parts of
town that I think are more prone to
cockroaches and I would have been more
understanding but like this particular
part of town is one of the cleaner maybe
the cleanest part of town and I was just
like so disgusted like so freaked out so
disappointed and I just feel like I
don't know part of me thought we were
gonna come back and after like nobody
being outside like no one leaving trash
no pollution like I felt like everything
was gonna be like a little bit cleaner
like the earth needed us to take a break
you know but actually I never seen so
many cockroaches in my life it was so
disgusting and it's so weird that that's
just like coming out of my mouth like a
normal thing and people who like live in
Arizona or like what the [ __ ] you know
but it's just a part of living here and
it's like that was like the nail in the
coffin for me with New York I think I'm
[ __ ] done anything I'm Donnie to
telling you I'm done like I am gonna
start making plans like for myself
personally to you know have ulterior
options so I just want everyone to know
that like I'm making moves
um and I just I can't wait for anyone
else anymore I have to do it for myself
cuz if not now when
so no sharing that story with me so that
I do not need to experience it on my own
because I was probably gonna go to the
restaurant that you went to last night
because it's like the nicest restaurant
without fresco dining so and I hate and
I don't want to say the restaurant
because I can't stress enough how it's
not where else like it anywhere else I
would have had the same exact experience
no and like this is one of the nicer
restaurants in the city like we would
eat there all the time before warranty
and I never saw Koch forage so it's not
their fault it was just insanity like
I've never felt like I was in Jurassic
Park more like it was just like it was
truly an out-of-body experience so I
wonder I'm curious to if any of our New
York toasters had alfresco dining and
had a better
experience than me um let me know yeah
Wow
sickening thanks for the heads up um but
other than that just another day here I
did a virtual live method class
yesterday and I am so sore I hadn't
worked out in a while and I just I can
barely stand or sit so luckily I don't
have to do either of those things on the
show um we also yesterday recorded a
fabulous patreon episode which was a
suggestion from someone it is up if you
want to do our page remember you can
listen to it now and if you're not a
patreon member you can pay $8 a month to
have access I think now it's like over
200 episodes from the past so we do
videos we do podcast episodes and this
one that we just did was a podcast
episode and it was fabulous yeah it was
fabulous and the one before it didn't
really get that much PR on our end but
it's one of the better blogs we've ever
made where Claudia Margo came over to my
apartment we got drunk and made a pizza
and it's [ __ ] hilarious and just
steamy and fun and if you're looking for
great blog head over there I said more
of a short film because it's 30 minutes
I don't know if I've loved is 30 minutes
know a vlog would be like a degrading
label for the piece of art we put
together I agree so it's a short film um
head on over to patreon.com/scishow
morning toasts for other short films as
well and the episode that we recorded
yesterday which is all about our
favorite things right now like from
every category on earth like just what
is getting us through and speaking of
art I would be remiss if I didn't
mention that we are one week out from
the release of my debut comedy special
you can pre-order it on iTunes if you
type disgraced Queen into iTunes or you
could just tap the link in my bio on
girl with no job on Instagram um I would
really appreciate the support I cannot
wait for it to come out I feel like I'm
just you know on loop like talking about
it but once it comes out and we get to
watch it together everyone's just gonna
know what we're talking about all the
time and I'm really excited so please
preorder it once it's out it'll be
available on a couple other streaming
platforms but if you want to support now
where you want to just get yourself a
receipt
you could pre-order it on iTunes at the
link in my bio on girls no job great
well I think without further ado it's
time I'm not gonna lie I have a little
bit of a migraine today I took one of my
magic pills like right before the show
so hopefully it dissolves over the
course of the show but right now I'm in
pain so let's let's get to it
without further ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and I don't feel
RGH today because I'm excited about
today's sponsor because as we promised a
few weeks ago we are going to start
highlighting black owned businesses here
in the morning to post and donating our
ad space to them so today's episode is
brought to you by local human founded by
Isaac Rochelle a defensive end for the
LA Chargers is an apparel company
focused on impacting local communities
they started it at the beginning of
quarantine and since then have donated
over thirteen thousand dollars to
various organizations local human
strives to serve and support local
communities by aligning with and
financially supporting organizations
that empower our communities local
humans they are one for one company
meaning they will be donating a shirt
for every shirt bought specifically
they'll be donating these brand new
shirts to foster centers around the
country but they go a step further by
donating 10 dollars per shirt to the
organization of the month each month a
local human will release a t-shirt and
partner with a nonprofit organization
philanthropic initiative or get creative
and give back this month local humans
has local human has partnered with three
organizations campaign zerah which
focuses on changing legislation in order
to reduce police violence the United
Negro College Fund which envisions a
nation where all Americans have equal
access to a college education and the
National Fair Housing Alliance which
works to eliminate housing
discrimination to ensure equal housing
opportunities for all people through
education outreach and public policy
initiatives a hundred percent of the
proceeds for this t-shirt will be
donated equally to these three
organizations to find out more about
local human shop they're more than a tee
campaign and learn about the
organization it's currently working with
go to local human dotco every time you
buy a shirt give a shirt and you also
donate money to three worthy causes make
sure the three that I just mentioned for
this month and they change every month
which is fabulous so again that link is
local human CEO local Human Co where you
can shop they're more than a tee
campaign and learn more about the
organization's they are currently
working with thank you local human for
partnering with us love it okay first
story NASCAR drivers are standing with
Bubba Wallace after a noose was found in
his stall after noose was found in Bubba
Wallace's garage stall fellow racers
showed their solidarity by walking his
car down the Talladega Superspeedway
have you seen this video of the drivers
and the car it is Jesse's so beautiful
it is but like this is where I get torn
up inside it's like why did something
like I'm glad that this video would like
happen and everyone supported Bubba
Blake why did Bubba have to experience
like opening up his locker and finding a
news when he's just like trying to
[ __ ] do his job you know no I know
but you know what it's like whoever put
that noose there like [ __ ] discussing
heinous crime and they probably thought
like we're gonna we're gonna cause
something it within NASCAR and instead
like the entire NASCAR community rallied
around Bubba and like they're it's never
been more clear where they stand how
they feel and that little who might do
something like that are not included in
this community and I just feel like
these stories like very unfortunately
like you hear stories like this a lot
like a you know a racist graffiti like
and I feel like we never find out who
did it but like with this one like I
want to know I need magicka Hargitay on
the case like we need to find out like
it's so important that like there's this
like level of anonymity when it comes to
being racist where it's like you get a
look nobody ends up finding out like who
[ __ ] in you know through whatever at
someone's house like no no we need you
full circle we need to find out who did
it and I literally want their name
plastered everywhere like they and their
family should be embarrassed yes well I
saw my newsletter this morning that the
Justice Department is getting involved
in the investigation to find out leftist
what happened so I really hope that we
get some answers I mean his garage stall
should have been like it's pretty
premium so maybe there's cameras and
hopefully we'll get an answer and there
will be responsibility and
accountability because this is so [ __ ]
up but I'm so proud of them I mean I'm
not like the biggest NASCAR stand but
like I'm just so proud of like NASCAR
they're just there's not only a lot of
preconceived notions about NASCAR and
like you know the community but it's
nice to see that like everyone is
just on board and I don't really follow
NASCAR and I've never heard of Bubba but
like homeboy can get it like he's cute
homeboy can truly get it I just started
following him on Instagram and it's
premium premium content and he's
sponsored by McDonald's so like he posts
these like McDonald's ads in his feet
and it seems like it's a dream and I
just I feel very terribly guilty that
like this had to happen for me to find
out who Bubba is because like I said I
don't follow NASCAR but now that he's
here I'm just so excited yeah I'm
excited to know him and to follow along
and you know it like NASCAR is really
like showing up and maybe it's time for
us to show up for NASCAR like and yes
with what it's the first sport that's
like back on the track but without fans
but once the fans are back like maybe
we'll be in those stands I don't know
maybe maybe I stand for NASCAR right so
NASCAR what's good um I just want to
make a point like I will be following up
with NASCAR in a few weeks like to find
out like because these stories like
unfortunately they're not that uncommon
and then like you never hear the
resolution like what happened to me find
out who did it if you get punished if
you go to jail like some you know I will
be following up I think this is so
[ __ ] heinous like I will be following
up yes definitely thank you for for your
follow up for in your follow-through hi
just following up here but I'm gonna be
emailing now circling die sorry for the
delay following up on this Thanks
see you bye Olo yo D EXO Claudia perfect
okay next story is kind of shocking for
me at least I'm curious to get your
thoughts because Carly parse known to
some people by as Carly Pierce but known
to the Steen's as Carly parse files for
divorce from Michael Rea after less than
a year of marriage after eight months of
marriage the every little thing
singer/songwriter filed for divorce from
her husband they just like keep putting
like the blank singer in a singer like
we know they get we though they are
filed for divorce from her husband on
Friday that Rex confirmed to people
they said they put out a statement
saying or a source close to par said
this was a hard decision it wasn't
something she wanted to have to do this
hasn't been a quarantine realization it
was a last resort they last appeared in
public together on June 6 when they both
performed without a live audience at the
Grand Old Opry
they were joined on the bill by Steve
Wariner and Lee price um
I cannot get over this like it is the
weirdest thing ever
and I feel like in a lot of ways like
they got married they met like it all
happened so fast
and I don't know like I guess we should
have seen this coming but I just didn't
I didn't see this coming I didn't like
think about it and honestly usually when
like a couple gets married they don't
like repot my divorce radar for at least
a year
a few honours and these two there was
something like so immediate about their
love and their marriage that made it
thing let made you think like they've
been friends forever and they just woke
up one morning and like they knew and
like this was it this was the end of the
road not the beginning of a new road so
it's definitely surprising um that they
like I got divorced soon after what's
your theory I have a theory about what I
think happened um and this is just pure
conjecture just like we vote we've met
them both we but live always on a red
carpet so we I don't know them at all
like for real it's just a vibe that I'm
getting I just be like Michael ray is
like a jealous guy when it comes to like
career stuff and I don't know I just
feel like in a lot of ways like he
popped on the scene and then like really
like his peak was like the day he
started you know naming and now he's
just like kind of floating around and
Carly parks is really like on her way
she got nominated for CMA best new
artist and she is that fabulous son uh
you're happy now and I don't know I just
feel like he couldn't deal with like her
rising star and his slowly falling star
that is just my guess okay I I don't
feel that um and I do sort of have a
theory but like it's it's too much
assumptions they send someone else for
me to share with the class you know what
I mean like it's just not like that's
like what we do here we like to share no
nobody's saying I'm not gonna like start
like labeling people you know
okay what'd you think one of them
cheated no no maybe maybe actually that
like kind of would make sense
I don't know how logistical II like you
cheat on someone in quarantine and it's
like so hard yeah I guess you could be
like I'm going to get essentials
essential DIC today's episode title the
essential dick yeah so this was just
really shocking to me you like we'll
find out eventually you know so I'm just
gonna sit back and bide my time we'll
follow up in a few weeks of course no no
I can't explain like how this was really
shocking but at the same time like not
shocking at all like there was always
something weird about their marriage
like a in the way that had happened be
like the way that they were so [ __ ]
thirsty like at every man every magazine
like even he or she by the way it's like
a direct source from scarlet parts like
it's obviously her like it's just there
was something so inherently like obvious
and weird about it that I'm not shocked
that it happened I am shocked that it
happened so quickly because they were so
fierce in their love for one another and
in professing it to every magazine and
every stop on the red carpet like that's
what shocks me is that they admit yeah
you know yeah of course so I think
something happened you know I think like
if they were just like unhappy and
unsure like you can go on for years like
that um especially when like your
relationship is good for your career and
everybody loves you and it's like yeah
and that's what they were you know every
I feel like everyone in the country
community was so excited to see them
together and so I think something
happened and maybe whatever I would love
to know what you think I just I just
don't think it's appropriate to like you
know speculate on someone like throw out
some some labels okay and what do I know
it was like I don't know anything so I
just don't think it's appropriate so um
that's that on that I'm gonna shift to a
little more happy couple news because I
did something crazy last night and I
watch a bit of The Bachelor greatest of
all time because it was Ben Higgins
season and not even cuz there's Ben
Higgins season but like every week that
promo for the show has gotten me a
little more interested in watching it
and then like
I was facetiming with the snatcher at
8:02 she's like I'm turning on bachelor
and I'm like they got me they got me at
the right time the snatchler did her
magic and now I am turned so um some
bits of news came out of it a lot of
wish wheelchair right now
first up Kaelyn Miller keys and Dean
Englert explained their commitment rings
quote we're in this for the long haul
so Kaelyn and Dean came on last night
and they are just weirdly like the most
perfect cutest couple ever like the
couple that makes no sense in this world
and like so stable like it was a little
weird in paradise but the second they
left Mexico like they have never once
wavered in their commitment to one
another yeah and so they were just like
talking about their relationship the van
life they lived in Santa Monica and how
they really just like you know what
they've been doing the last year in
Chris Harrison asked them if they're
married because they wear wedding rings
and Dean like was for a little cage at
first but then he said um in my opinion
I don't need the title of husband to
show the world that I'm committed to one
person the fact that I'm wearing the
ring is showing that I'm committed to
Kaelyn and only Kaelyn and I've been
wearing it for the past six months or so
he said that him and Kaelyn are in a
domestic partnership
she said she wears her fun little ring
as well which isn't the ring of
traditional marriage or engagement but
it's our way of telling the world and
the people were around that we are
committed to each other I mean this is
like so like Dean's thing and Kaitlyn
has obviously adopted it but whatever
like I just love them and it's obviously
not what I would do but every different
strokes for different folks they seem
really really happy together in their
like weird you know surfer life and I'm
just I ship I stand I'm at the port
standing with my ship know at the port
standing with my ship they just were so
in sync last night she is so beautiful
but she just had this glow about her
like just this happy couple glow and I I
think it's cool like obviously that's
not what we've chosen to do with our
lives like we are married um but I like
their mentality meat you know it's very
sweet and very romantic and I like I
said I'm standing at the port with my
ship and I'm waiting for it to come in
yeah
okay next story also something that
happened last night that I was really
taken by so I wanted to discuss it wait
okay actually no you go Ben Higgins is
apologizing to bachelor villain Olivia
Carini for his lack of wisdom and
maturity
Olivia Creedy has come a long way since
first thing onto the reality TV scene as
one of the bachelors most memorable
villains she returned to the franchise
last night for the first time in four
years to reflect on her experience where
she looked back on Ben Higgins season in
2016
appearing via video chat from her home
in Austin she recalled how her
relationship with Ben crashed and burned
after a promising start
she said that Hagan that Ben Higgins was
quote everything I thought he was going
to be she said her confidence was shaken
when she noticed that he was developing
connections with other people quote I
think that's when I self-destructed
completely because I was trying to find
a way to make it happen when I probably
knew in my head that it wasn't going to
happen okay so I watched her segment she
talks a lot about like what happened on
the season how she went from my first
impression rose to dumped in a windy
Bahamas Island but she also talked a lot
about her experience watching the show
and what that was like for her and like
how devastating it was like to one watch
the show in here like other girls talked
badly about you your physical appearance
and just like make fun of you and then
also you know the public element of
being on the show and like not wanting
to go out and like how much she
struggled with it through the years and
like she I mean we've known her for a
long time and like we've unknown for a
long time that she's not the person that
she was on the show and that she's a
fabulous hilarious such a sweet girl but
literally the nicest girl you've ever
met the nicest girl you've ever met
which is so crazy considering like when
I was even watching the season and I was
like oh my god I can't believe that's
the same Olivia that we know like it's
crazy she was incredible last night like
she was so smart and funny and like
honest and she she was talking like I
feel like she was really quote-unquote
cancelled before like now it's just you
know a template and I feel like the
Queen right the person who came after
her I think was Corinne who handled it
completely differently and really turned
it on its head and I think she did an
amazing job at that but I think Olivia
really struggled at the time and like
she got an apology for Ben four like him
not
having her back while the season was
airing and kind of just like let people
get carried away with the things that
they were saying about her which was
really kind of him to do um but I think
it was more of it was more of a
commentary on the culture and like
bachelor nation and like why do we do
this to people you know on it's very
sweet Bennigan's is such a nice guy
never once did I blame what Olivia
Creedy went through on Ben Higgins like
he was [ __ ] busy trying to find the
love of his life and it's very sweet
that he apologized and it's not on me to
forgive him but like I don't think that
was necessary like if they're really
gonna go in why don't we talk to some of
the editors who decided to portray
Olivia Creed II in a certain way or Mike
Fleiss who obviously has you know a
large hand in deciding you know who gets
portrayed in what's light and who gets
portrayed in a negative light like I
don't really understand been kind of
taking the fall but he's lovely to do it
but Olivia Creedy deserves justice and
it's not really in the form of an
opinion of an apology from anything
wrong yeah I agree with that
he liked the moment he feels like he
could have gone on Twitter when the show
was airing and then like no Olivia's a
great girl like you're not seeing her
the way that I saw and I just want to
say like I've never seen a stronger
connection on The Bachelor the night one
Olivia crazy and Ben Higgins like I had
my bachelor bracket done locked and
loaded and I was like this is it and
then after the episode aired they showed
like the previews for the season it was
like her against the world and I was
completely shocked
so we met Olivia Creedy in your old
apartment building during her season
right it might have been as it was
airing or like a month later you know
she it was I didn't move to New York
like as it was airing so it was probably
right after her season aired and she
moved to New York and we met her in my
building and then like she lived in New
York for a while and we've been like
good friends since yeah and I just
remember thinking like this is the girl
she's so nice and simple like what's the
what's the big mystery do ya know I
remember feeling the same way of
watching it back last night I was like
oh my god I I it's shocking yeah and in
a lot of ways I'm like glad again that
like she had this like moment of
retribution but it's like on behalf of
bachelor nation it's like a little too
little too late first of all and - it's
like we're going in like let's find the
true person accountable like
let's find the person who clicked copy
paste yep yes let's I mean hopefully I
was gonna say about Ben Higgins season
is um I didn't watch the thing last
night but I watch you and it was on the
air and I spent I have said since that
day that I really felt like Ben should
have chosen Jojo like it was to me it
was so obvious that Jojo was the winner
like he loved her so much like and I
don't know and and by the way he meant
Lauren didn't even end up working out so
like I wonder if he ever thinks like hmm
what if I went with Jojo what would my
life look like like I have never seen a
bigger greater love on The Bachelor than
the one between Ben and Lauren like even
as I was watching it back last night
it's just they had this like connection
where they didn't even they didn't have
to say all the stuff to each other like
when she told him she loved him it was
just like a giggle and a slip out and
like she's covering her face and crying
when he said it back it was just like
messy and so cute and then when Jojo
said it it was like I just feel like you
know this is so hard for me like typical
bachelor [ __ ]
and even though watching a fact last
night I was like oh they definitely had
something senior than I remember it
being like Ben and Lauren there's a
reason they were happily ever after like
and I know they didn't worry warrant I
know that no but like they were the
right people for each other at the time
and not for forever but for the year and
you know I know sadly how they are just
they are the greatest over time it's so
funny how like we watched the same
season and you would think that like the
winner would be so obvious but like
really everyone experiences it
differently like I really thought back
then and then watching their reality
show Ben and Lauren happily-ever-after
where they like had to go to brunch with
Jojo and Jordan like I was like it's so
obvious he's still in love with Jojo no
no I wonder if he ever thinks about her
I genuinely I'm curious I don't know I
always saw it as like he told Lauren he
loved her because he wasn't gonna let
the woman that he loves say it and him
leaving hanging so then like he had to
say - Jojo - to even the plane
Elden like I just always saw it through
that prism up like Jojo like he did to
Joe Joe what Joe Joe did to Robby like
just bringing someone to the end for the
sake of having two people there right
yeah but but Joe Joe was a like a
fabulous for any candidate and Robby was
nothing on the sword and you know it
I've just actually been thinking about
Jourdan and Jojo a lot because I guess
their wedding date was their original
wedding date was like a week ago um and
they were posting about how they were
supposed to getting married that day but
because of her a virus they obviously
had to push it off and I just like
totally forgot about that and they like
to me when they were watching season I
had the most doubts about them to me
they were just so obviously like thirsty
and in it for the fame and I do still
think they're thirsty but I do really
feel like their love is real like I
believe in their love I believe in their
love I don't think that they're thirsty
because like I'm not watching them drink
you know like they are just living their
life there it's not like they moved to
LA and they are I know they have their
like TV show how slipping but like
that's truly what Jojo did before the
show I actually think the proof is
always in the pudding and like they have
turned out to be like rock solid and
therefore everything happens for a
reason
also I didn't finish watching the show
but I'll finish watching and I'm sure
they mentioned that like Ben Higgins is
happily engage him to like such a cute
human being not that I know her but just
from Instagram and so and like Lauren is
so happily married and so it all works
out again
but like it had to go this way for Ben
to end up with Jess Clark for Lauren to
end up Lauren Lane and for Jojo to end
up with Jordan Rogers so everything
happened the way it was supposed to and
everything happens for a reason and you
can really see that as evident in Ben
Hagen season of The Bachelor
no and it's just one of the greatest
it's truly in front of the greatest
seasons of all time and also I enjoyed
watching it because it hurts me back to
the days when I was so into The Bachelor
you know and like up on everything and
it just like it reminded me of when and
why and how I used to love The Bachelor
yes
also not again that I didn't watch it
but I saw people watching it on
Instagram and they were just like
showing the actual TV and it is insane
how different all the contestants look
like
Jojo looks judged as a different person
Lauren is a different person Amanda's a
different person back as a different
person like they all just like glowed up
so hard and it's like I can't believe
this is what it looks like when they
were on TV because in my mind like what
they look like now it's what they've
always look like ya know it's insane but
they also like I'm sure everyone's like
they got so much more fun which I'm sure
like people have had work done like a
little lip here a little chin there but
you can also make look so like like
babies baby so young and it's really
crazy to see also like seeing Amanda's
daughters on the show like I'm like
cousin Charlie there on my TV yeah it
was just it was that missing really fun
to watch like I understand what like
what they're trying to do but it also
goes to show that the one season of The
Bachelor can be distilled into three
hours that is a fabulous point and it
also goes to show you like the glory
days of The Bachelor franchise are
certainly behind us I think maybe we'll
see we'll see I am really hopeful for
Matt James um Oh Instagram and I'm so
excited about it
but we still have clear season before
it's just just the funniest thing I
actually don't think I'm gonna watch
Claire season I actually was gonna be
done with the franchise all together but
I do want to support the first black
male lead so I will watch Matt's but I
don't really think I want to support and
I mean not support sorry I don't think I
want to watch Claire's I'm just like
it's such a commitment time emotions
yeah and then it gives me a migraine so
then I have to go into my magic pill
stash but they only give me six at a
time okay are you ready for a fifth and
final story it's a little random but I'm
a little random ooh it's a little random
be random new rhythm is yep random
business because it's from CNN business
and it's a roundup of some of the brands
that are a resale goldmine do you know
what I mean like like consignment
consignment yeah but from my guess is
low end yeah sure there's some that you
would guess but then there's some that
like you would in like thread up Cheri
O'Neill stock X no no what brands within
those like if you're selling your stuff
what brands
your [ __ ] have the highest resale value
what a weird article who [ __ ] cares
oh my god I could think that's cool like
what you could buy now that might hold
that you know yeah but also so let me
just get to it because um they spoke to
like thread up and real real and real
real is more high-end right up is more
low end so thread up really solicit
brands with the best overall resell
value on its platform which it
determines by assigning scores that take
into account a brand's demand virality
and value to the seller fight fry sorry
is a fire like fire vessel Oh fry dry
the leather goods company that's known
for its beloved boots top the list for a
second year in a row that's good to know
since got a pair of fries
other notable brands with excellent
resale value include fashion labels Tory
Burch Kate Spade and coach outdoor
clothing brand Patagonia also made it
into thread ups top 10 also eyewear
brand Ray Ban made the cut as did
eco-friendly clothing brand Reformation
which prides itself on using sustainable
fabrics on the luxury end real real
giggle imps into the top 10 brands that
have held the highest resale value on
the platform over glass decade on the
list are luxury brands ermes louis
vuitton spelled wrong gorg and Epiphanes
for air Maisie item that consistently
held the highest resale value is the
ultra pricey Hermes Birkin and I knew
where you get myself a Birkin totally a
new Birkin bag can cost close to 10
thousand dollars all the way up to
hundreds of thousands best for a new one
but a resale one could be less
meanwhile I have on the real real
meanwhile Gucci Fendi and your are the
top three back brands with the
fastest-growing resale value in the same
time period according to the real real I
mean all of that is pretty much what you
think it would be yeah I was surprised
to not hear Chanel on the real real one
interests and I wonder why well yeah I
don't know maybe CNN just didn't choose
to write about that one interesting I
mean i consign on the real real so I'll
just have to put
my ermes in one box actually one item
from Hermes and I caused it and I did
get it for free so I'll sell it okay
yeah
no I it just gets you thinking
ya know about value and the market the
market is quite interesting you know me
I'm always at the stock exchange you
know trade in making deals got two for
one one for two
you know I'm this woman special it's in
my blood 1 for 2
um anyway stories that you needed to
know that is all that she wrote I think
we got a jump because we got submissions
to do so yeah thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please if you to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also gas anywhere hi guys newfound so
spread by agents it Republican video I
already know place never uses pockets -
more interesting five-star view but a
beautiful stunning and summer we are bye
bye